One of the most exciting parts of this
machine learning engineer nano degree
program is that for the very first
time we are able to leverage
some of the materials that we've
produced as part of our partnership with
Georgia Tech on their online Master's
and Computer Science program.
You're going to be hearing from the same
videos, the same professors that teach
graduate level machine learning
at Georgia Tech right now.
You'll hear form Charles Isbell on
Michael Litman on the major schools of
thought on machine learning
like reinforcement learning and
supervised learning.
You'll hear from Goyle and I about
the more kindly oriented side of AI,
a different perspective
of what AI can do.
You'll also cover some classes
on applied machine learning,
specifically to certain domains
like trading and healthcare.
Now because these classes were produced
for the Georgia Tech online Masters
degree, they have their own learning
goals and we're using them in a way
that's a little bit different from
how they were originally produced.
So you might feel like it's
a little bit chaotic sometimes.
We'll try and
step in from time to time and
set the expectations and remind you
of what our learning goals are.
But we just wanted to let you know that
if you feel like it's a little bit
disjointed at times, that's intentional.
That kind of comes with the territory of
using the material that's been produced
for this master's program like this.